en el último vídeo introduje la noción
de transformación y cómo podríamos
pensarlo cuando tenemos funciones verdad
simplemente las pensamos como puntos que
se mueven de un espacio en otro y aquí
quiero mostrarte un ejemplo de cómo se
ve digamos cuando el espacio de entrada
es de dos dimensiones así que por
ejemplo aquí tenemos el espacio de
entradas
y aquí tenemos el espacio de entradas
que simplemente es una copia del plano
xy verdad y el espacio de salida también
es de dos dimensiones así que el espacio
de salidas en este caso es un plano de
dos dimensiones aquí está el espacio de
salidas ok entonces lo que quiero hacer
digamos es es correr una animación es un
ejemplo de una de estas transformaciones
y después vamos a entrar en más detalles
de digamos la función que hay detrás de
esta animación para que podamos entender
muy bien la transformación como un como
un todo verdad así que así es como se ve
la animación aquí vemos hacia dónde se
está dirigiendo vemos que es bastante
complicado hay un montón de puntos que
se están moviendo un montón de cosas
distintas están ocurriendo aquí y lo que
es muy común en este tipo de situaciones
es que cuando estamos pensando en el
movernos de dos dimensiones a dos
dimensiones en realidad lo podríamos
pensar en el mismo espacio en el plano
xy es decir vemos una copia de ese plano
que se mueve en sí mismo es decir vemos
el espacio de entrada y salida al mismo
tiempo y por cierto cuando digo vemos
no me refiero a que siempre vamos a
tener una animación como esta en
realidad cuando hablo de
transformaciones digamos es una idea
vaga que tengo en mi mente en algún lado
pero pero al menos ayuda a entender qué
es lo que está ocurriendo con esta
función y voy a hablar de esto más
adelante pero pero ahora vamos a ver qué
función es la que estamos viendo aquí
así que la función que le dije a la
computadora que anime aquí es una
función f que depende de dos variables x
y ye y esta función es x cuadrada voy a
hacer mejor esto
x cuadrada más que cuadrada este digamos
la componente x en nuestro vector y la
componente que será x cuadrada menos que
cuadrada así que sólo para ayudarnos
digamos a ir entendiendo esta función
vamos a tomar un punto relativamente
simple así que digamos por ejemplo
tomemos el origen tomemos el origen y
veamos dónde o más en cuál será el
vector salida del origen es decir veamos
quién es la imagen de 0 0 verdad
entonces cuando x y jenson ceros x
cuadrada más de cuadrada se hace 0 y x
cuadrada menos de cuadrada es 0 también
verdad
ambos son ceros es decir si vemos la
animación lo que significa es que este
punto se mantiene fijo con la
transformación es como como si
mantuvieran tu pulgar apretándolo y
realmente no le estaría pasando nada de
hecho por eso es que este punto le
llamamos un punto fijo de la función así
que este tipo de terminología en
realidad no tiene sentido a menos de qué
seguimos a la función como una
transformación así que fijémonos en otro
ejemplo aquí
pensemos en otro punto así que tomemos
digamos el punto 11 tomemos el punto 1 y
evaluemos la función en este punto así
que fijémonos por ahora solo en las
salidas ok solo en el espacio de salidas
aquí se encuentra el 11 y nos
preguntamos hacia dónde se va a mover
así que cuando sustituimos esto en
nuestra función tendremos uno al
cuadrado
1 al cuadrado y en la segunda componente
tendremos 1 al cuadrado menos 1 al
cuadrado entonces tendremos en la
primera componente 1 más 1 que es 2 y en
la segunda componente tendremos 1 menos
uno que es cero muy bien esto significa
que podríamos esperar que este punto se
mueva hacia el 20 de alguna forma así
que si nos fijamos de nuevo en la
transformación podemos esperar que este
punto se mueva justo por acá y
nuevamente puede ser difícil de seguir
porque hay un montón de cosas que se
están moviendo pero si somos cuidadosos
a la hora de observar este punto veremos
que cae justo donde habíamos dicho y en
principio podríamos hacer esto para
cualquier punto y tratar de entender
cómo es que se mueve de un lugar a otro
y tú podrías preguntar cuyín pero cuál
es el punto de todo esto si tenemos
otras formas de visualizar funciones que
quizás son más precisas y 'la para ser
honestos menos confusas por ejemplo los
campos vectoriales son muy buenas formas
para este tipo de funciones verdad
quizás las gráficas serían mejores para
las funciones con una entrada y una
salida de una o dos dimensiones y por
qué pensar en términos de
transformaciones y la razón principal es
conceptual no es como que siempre
tengamos una animación digamos en frente
y no vamos a poder hacer siempre a mano
digamos no vamos a poder evaluar un
montón de puntos y pensar cómo es que se
mueven para hay un montón de distintos
conceptos en matemáticas digamos con
funciones en particular que cuando los
entendemos en términos de una
transformación nos da un mayor
entendimiento de qué es lo que está
ocurriendo cosas como por ejemplo
derivadas o las variaciones de las
derivadas que vamos a aprender en este
mismo curso hay hay muchas formas de
entenderlas y en términos de por ejemplo
comprimido expandir el espacio y cosas
de ese estilo y que no siempre tienen
una buena analogía con digamos las
gráficas o los campos vectoriales así
que al menos le da más sabor a nuestro
entendimiento de las funciones también
las transformaciones son una parte súper
importante del álgebra
y llegar a un punto en donde estarás
aprendiendo la conexión entre el álgebra
lineal y el cálculo de varias variables
y si tienes una buena digamos un buen
concepto de las transformaciones tanto
en el contexto de álgebra lineal como en
el contexto de cálculo verás y estarás
mejor posicionado para entender la
conexión entre estos dos campos